okay so the public health establishment
denied the links between
the coronavirus and the wuhan institute
of virology for a year okay
fine and yes the media and big tech
totally covered up for them and
castigated anyone who ever suggested a
link
as a dangerous conspiracy theorist and
sure
fine leaked documents out of china do
now show
that the wuhan lab very likely had a lot
to do with the virus but
but the intrepid journalists at cnn
and the new york times they have found
the culprit can you guess who the
culprit is
i'll give you one two it's trump it's
obviously the culprit is trump
a lot of the discussion about the lab
leak i think was clouded early on
because there was a suggestion by
some that it was somehow a chinese
weapon
that that caused this that's not what
we're talking about here we're talking
about a lab
accident but we've come a long way from
people dismissing this as a conspiracy
theory
to a lot of people taking this seriously
maggie we have john and look i do think
it's important to
remember that part of the issue when
this was first being reported on and
discussed
back a few months after the pandemic had
begun was that then president
trump and mike pompeo the secretary of
state
both suggested they had seen evidence
that this was
formed in a lab and they also suggested
it was not released on purpose
but they refused to release the evidence
showing what it was and so because of
that
that made this instantly political i
think that
it was you know example 1000 when the
trump administration learned that when
you have burned your own credibility
over and over again
people are not immediately going to
believe you especially in an election
year
it's like that meme of that guy shooting
the other guy and he says
he says why did you do this why did you
why did you do this trump
these radicals have mutilated our
government they're mutilating our young
women
an increasing number of whom are coming
to regret transgender therapy we'll get
into
that they're mutilating our educational
institutions through critical race
theory
and mandatory porn workshops we will try
to detransition america i'm michael
knowles
this is the michael knowles show
[Applause]
[Music]
my favorite comment yesterday from
deborah gessner
who observes that fauci says we have
never
funded gain of function research and
fauci also says
and this is why we had to do it he does
he does that a little tricky he talks at
both sides of his mouth that fouchy
and he's really getting caught up in a
major
major lie how can you spot lies
well you got to be educated how can you
be educated
is it by going off to harvard uh no i
don't not necessarily
one great way to be educated the great
courses plus with the great courses plus
you will get
thousands of hours of fascinating
content across
hundreds of topics you can learn about
the history of the beatles
you can learn about american presidents
you can learn about cooking basics
all things that i actually am interested
in you you see there's the practical
stuff there's the tangible there's the
really intellectual i love it all it's
it's really tremendous
and what i love the lectures are
terrific but i love the technology here
because you can start it on your phone
you're driving yeah we have 15 minutes
in your car okay toss it on
then you stop right wherever you are you
can switch it over to your computer
you get home at night you got another 20
minutes before bed toss it on
your tv with a glass of wine way better
than wasting your time on some woke
nonsense that's streaming
on some tv channel do not miss out on
this great deal
go now to thegreatcoursesplus.com
knowles to get your free month when you
sign up for a quarterly plan
that is thegreatcoursesplus.com
knowles the argument here is that donald
trump
has squandered his credibility and
therefore
when he suggested and when mike pompeo
the secretary of state suggested that
there might be some link between
the virus and the viral institute that
was 400 yards away from where it was
allegedly discovered
that's why nobody believed them in the
mainstream media a lot of us believed
him and we talked about it
for a long time even beginning last year
but the mainstream media because trump
just lied about so many things 10
zillion lies that the new york times
covered the trump he's such a liar
where did he squander his credibility
where is it what's the lie i guess the
big lie they point to
is that he's he said that his crowd
sizes
were like a thousand or so a few
thousand people larger than they were
or something is that because by my count
donald trump when he had a disagreement
with the media
was right about virtually everything
and the media and the left but i repeat
myself were wrong about virtually
everything
he was right about the virus he called
remember early on he said this virus is
probably a little bit worse than
an ordinary flu so we're going to shut
down travel from china the media said
this is
actually joe biden himself said this is
hysterical xenophobia and then
turned out trump was right about that
but then trump also said it's not as bad
as now they are making it out to be he
was right about that too
he was right about the vaccine do you
remember when donald trump was arguing
with
chris wallace and joe biden at that
two-on-one presidential debate
when trump said yeah we're gonna get a
vaccine within a month or two we're
gonna get the vaccine very quickly
it's gonna be ready to go by the end of
the year and we're gonna have people
vaccinated by april and they said
you're that's crazy donald you've never
all of the experts and your own experts
say that it won't happen and he said i
don't know what you what they're telling
you but yeah that's what's gonna happen
he was right
the trade deals you remember the trade
deals he's going to destroy the global
economy what happened the economy went
up
up up up up peace in israel do you
remember that trump
he can't just deal with the arab states
that's crow what an idiot he's putting
jared kushner and avi berkowitz in
charge of
middle east peace and what happens
doubles the number of nations that
recognize israel gives us relative peace
in the middle east
nato oh no he's going to abandon our
nato allies nope they're just going to
start paying more money like he said
they would
lots and lots of other things i mean
that barely scratches the surface but i
just if you look at the facts
every big issue where trump disagreed
with the liberal establishment
just about every single one he was right
and they were wrong
he's got way way more credibility than
the libs do and it's on this wuhan
virology institute point as well
he said yeah i think it probably has
something to do with the lab the media
say absolutely no it doesn't now they
got to fall in line we're seeing this
more and more each day scott gottlieb
who was the former fda commissioner
under trump
has now come out he said there is
growing circumstantial evidence that the
lab had something to do with the virus
and he said this
not on newsmax not on oan not in the
right-wing media
he pointed it out on cnbc now we know
that three of the people who were
who were sick based on this latest
report were actually hospitalized and
the timing of that
would put it you know sufficiently early
that it could have triggered this
epidemic there's now more and more
reporting and more and more analysis
that probably the first cases occurred
at some point in the sort of october
november time frame and so the timing of
these infections
would put it within within that realm i
think the challenge right now is that
the
uh the side of the ledger that supports
the thesis that this came from a
zoonotic source from an animal source
hasn't budged
and the side of the ledger that
suggested this could have come out of a
lab has been continuing to grow
so you got this evidence and and scott
gottlieb is trying to be very
diplomatic here he's saying look you
know there was evidence that it was from
a
an animal source just a totally natural
source without any
connection with the wuhan institute but
now the evidence that it's from the lab
is beginning to grow
i think he's being a little too
diplomatic here anybody with two brain
cells to rub together
could have deduced a year ago when the
bat coronavirus escaped right next to
the bat coronavirus lab
that huh maybe the bat coronavirus lab
has something to do with it
that doesn't take a rocket science it
doesn't take an epidemiologist
it doesn't take a dr fauci to come to
that conclusion but there was a lot of
political pressure
not to come to that conclusion and by
the way they had a lot of intel
even last year as maggie haberman was
admitting
on on the news show that there was a lot
of intel that
trump and pompeo alluded to last year
that the mainstream media
simply chose to ignore and mike pompeo
former secretary of state is now
discussing this very intel on television
and he is pointing out
a lot of other people in the public
health sector
had this intel as well we spent a lot of
time working on this problem set in
january we were able to declassify a
whole lot of material that i knew about
much earlier
i made remarks over a year go down early
may of 2020
talking about this risk and it was
outrageous it was outrageous to see
scientists
even government us government scientists
who were denying this when
they surely must have seen the same
information that i had seen that that
includes certainly dr fauci as well
we need to know what happened here the
chinese communist party knows
what happened here they know who patient
zero was they know precisely where this
began
these three individuals who became sick
the symptoms were consistent with what
someone would get
that we'd be symptomatic of if they had
covet 19 the wuhan virus
we need to get to the bottom of this
because this could happen again they're
still conducting research in these
same laboratories today it's being done
in ways that were similar to what
happened back
over a year ago this is dangerous we
could end up with something much
much like this again being focused upon
the world the united
states has a responsibility to demand
that the chinese communist party
give us the things that they simply know
dana and bill
they know the answer to these things and
they refuse to hand over this
information
who had the information and when is that
you know mike pompeo also a bit
diplomatic he was the nation's top
diplomat
he is sandwiching that in here he's
discussing the virus and the connections
he's discussing the virus and the
connections at the end and in the middle
he says
dr fauci had the same intel that i did
these public health
geniuses had the same intel that i did
and they chose not to talk about it
i do not have a top secret security
clearance okay
i am not privy to the secret intel that
all these guys were getting
and yet i knew that there was a
great likelihood that that wuhan
institute had something to do with it
you're telling me that dr fauci did not
plus dr fauci had intelligence that we
all are not privito
and you're telling me that he did not
this guy who is who has lied to us
outright lied to us about pretty pretty
important things
during this pandemic from the very
beginning he lied to us about his true
views on the efficacy of masks
what else are they lying to you about
this this is the thing that i think
really
separates the the right the true
right-wingers you know not i'm not
talking about the squishy people who
basically just
exist to prop up the liberal
establishment i'm not talking about the
ones who write op-eds in the washington
post about how terrible republicans are
and that sort of thing yeah
you know which ones i'm alluding to the
ones who think that drag queen story
hour is a blessing of liberty i'm not
talking about them
i'm talking about the actual
conservatives the actual right-wingers
the big thing that separates us
from the libs i think is
perspective sure ideology whatever sure
it's that the conservative has seen
the dishonesty the conservative it's
it's that example
drew uses this a lot you're reading the
newspaper and you say okay
here's an article about iran i guess
they're right okay here's an article
about the economy i guess they're right
here's an article about the yankees wait
a second i know something about the
yankees and this article's wrong this
isn't the truth
oh well here's an article about foreign
trade i guess they're right
you think the one thing i know about i
can tell they're being dishonest here
but i guess i'm going to continue to
believe them on other things
when the liberal establishment is this
corrupt they have such a losing track
record
they keep getting things wrong and wrong
and wrong whether through
incompetence or through dishonesty
intentional lies
if you recognize that then you're just
not going to fall for it and you think
what else are they lying to me about
maybe sure they're lying about some of
the virus stuff
yeah they're lying about this that and
the other thing but there are even big
lies if i can borrow a phrase that's
very popular right now
a big one the probably the biggest
ideological
delusion that's being foisted on us
right now is transgenderism it's having
really negative effects
for a lot of women and girls got to
protect yourself from this stuff one
great way to protect yourself
from threats outside ring i love knowing
that at my house we can protect
ourselves against
you know the bad guys who want to break
in but we can even protect ourselves
against unwanted house guests i'm not
saying the in-laws i'm not i'm just
saying i like to know who is on the
doorstep
before i open the door okay and with
ring and with rings easy to install
indoor and outdoor cameras you can see
and speak
to whoever is at your door head on over
to ring.com
knowles it's a great way to start your
ring experience and i say start because
they've got solutions everywhere easy to
install
you can do it yourself super duper cool
makes me feel very safe when i'm on the
road
because i know not just that i can check
in on my house or something like that
but i just know that sweet little elise
and cute little june will know who is
outside that door
before they open the door really
great way great housewarming gift too
because it's super cool keeps your
friends safe and not that expensive so
you get credit for a great gift you
don't have to shell out a lot head on
over to ring today ring.com
knowles to get your ring alarm security
kit you can build the system that's
right for your home and have it up and
running in minutes that's not an
exaggeration
ring.com knowles that's ring.com knowles
the big delusional ideology that is
being pushed right now by the liberal
establishment it's not just by the blue
haired radicals on the crazy college
campus in the middle of nowhere
this is an ideology being pushed by the
biggest corporations the biggest tech
platforms
and and the government itself
transgenderism
it's not don't forget you've got
major companies all waving the
transgender flag did you know there's a
transgender flag apparently there is
and this is everyone's celebrating this
sort of thing the actress ellen page
uh who is now calling herself elliot but
you know i think i'm gonna stop doing
this i think i'm going to stop indulging
in the name changes because
we for a long time have set up we're not
going to indulge in
the pronouns because i'm not going to
call her
him you can't force me to lie some
people are
doing that though some people are going
along with it or they're they're just
choosing not to use the pronouns or
they're going to use the
the singular they as though you know
we've got a lot of demons inside of us
and
we are legion or something we're not but
we've said okay you know
we on the conservative side who said
we're not going to go with the pronouns
but we will call them whatever name they
want if they you know
anyone can change their name that's
perfectly fine
no i don't think so caitlyn is a girl's
name
caitlyn's not a boy's name so if i refer
to caitlyn jenner as him but i
continue to refer to him as caitlyn i'm
still kind of confusing the issue aren't
i
i don't know that you can just go along
and change your name willy-nilly like
that
it's a little confusing because you've
got george elliot one of the greatest
female novelists of all time and you've
got
uh evil and wah it's not a lady not
evelyn you know it's not a
not a gal uh he's a guy so i know look
there's a little ambiguity with the
names a little more so than with the
pronouns but
i think i'm gonna have to go with ellen
page so ellen page posts this photo of
herself topless
this photo would not be permitted for if
any other woman did it but because
ellen page is pretending to be a man she
gets to post this picture
and she looks much more like a boy she's
had breast
mutilation she's got some abs now i
don't know if that was surgical or if
that's
uh you know from lifting weights or
something like that from doing crunches
you can tell i don't really know exactly
how these uh muscle groups are developed
that's not my thing
uh wearing men's swim trunks and saying
you know look i'm i'm a boy now look
look how happy i big smile on her face
a lot of women and girls and a lot of
boys and men that for that matter are
now seeing this and saying how
wonderful it is i can choose to
look like the other sex i can really
become the other sex if i suffer
either from a psychological delusion
that i am or
from this impulse that i very much want
to be this or if it's just i'm taken up
in the
social contagion that boys or girls and
girls are boys and i think that's cool
so you know if a girl goes through a
tomboy phase when she's 12
all of a sudden she's going to mutilate
her body in some ways that are
irreversible
there is another side here as you can
probably tell from the way that i'm
discussing this issue there is another
side here there's a lot of regret
going on and cbs news got to give them
got to give them credit
where credit's due 60 minutes ran a
special
about transgender regret and the girls
who regret looking like boys and the
boys who regret looking like girls
in her early 20s grace ledinsky smith
was seriously depressed
and developed gender dysphoria she began
searching for answers
in transgender communities on the
internet and when i saw them being so
happy and excited
about doing this wonderful
transformative process to really like
become their true selves
it was like have i considered that this
could be my situation
too grace says she found a gender
therapist on the internet
and told her i'm thinking of
transitioning
because she was over 18 and didn't need
parental consent
she says she merely signed an informed
consent form at a clinic
and got hormone shots just four months
after she started testosterone
she says she was approved for a
mastectomy what's called
top surgery that she told us was
traumatic
i started to have a really disturbing
sense that like a part of my body
was missing almost a ghost limb feeling
about being like there's something that
should be there and the feeling really
surprised me but it was really hard to
deny
and so she detransitioned by going off
testosterone
you get the idea this goes on and on i
recommend you watch the whole thing
very pretty girl going through a bad
period where she was depressed
and then some perverts and and psychos
and
and idiots i mean to be to be fair to
them some of these people might just be
stupid but i think a lot of them are
just perverts and they're
they're preying on people's confusion
but some of them might just be totally
ignorant and stupid
they take advantage of this and they say
oh yeah you want to mutilate yourself
you want to lop off perfectly healthy
organs fine by me here you go
and by the way it's not just children
you'll hear the
a lot of conservatives say well you know
look whatever adults want to do that's
fine but
just don't do it to the kids well she
was an adult right this this woman was
18 years old
do you think it's right that some
pervert
doctor was was able to facilitate this
depressed troubled woman's decision to
mutilate her own body
which she almost instantly came to
regret and has now gone back a little
bit
but has suffered irreversible damage do
you think that's good
i don't i think there are
you know as there often are i think
there are probably three positions on
this issue
the left's position is trans everybody
including and especially the kids
right drag queen story hour into schools
let's confuse kids on their sex
let's teach kids in preschool as they're
doing in brooklyn that little boys can
be little girls and let's get everybody
on transgender ideology
then there's the middle squish position
which a lot of self-styled conservatives
hold
which is bad for kids but if adults want
to mutilate their bodies totally fine
and then there's the actual conservative
position which is i don't care if you're
18 i don't care if you're 80
you should not be able to do this
doctors should not
be mutilating perfectly healthy body
parts and
people who are troubled and want to do
this or believe that they
have to do this to be their true selves
are disturbed people and they need
psychological help but they don't need
their bodies mutilated to make their
problems worse
that's those are the those are the three
positions pick your choice
they're you know the the the left
authoritarian position
and then the nice wonderful liberal
open-minded position like
women such as this who are 18 years old
should be able to mutilate themselves
even if they're going to regret it
terribly
and then there's the right-wing
authoritarian they're going to call it
authoritarian position
that you shouldn't be able to mutilate
perfectly healthy body parts and take
advantage of disturbed people
where do you fall in that issue i think
you can tell which side
i fall on it's horrible what we've done
to these girls and it's it's
obviously this is a the topic of abigail
schreier's book irreversible damage
which i
i think i blurbed that book i loved it
so much in
the advanced copy and then it became a
big uh big seller so i recommend you go
out and read that one this is not just
one isolated case that cbs news is
covering
this is happening a lot and it's in it
happening increasingly
and for parents who don't know what to
do i i understand how confused one would
be especially if your kid's going to
public school
where this insanity is being foisted on
them constantly and you've got a kid who
is very confused about this i understand
it's a hard decision
what do i do what do i you've got a
family member who's going through this
but
there's a dark side to this story that
only very rarely comes out into public
light so
well done to cbs for recovering it at
all
these are transparent lies to tell that
pretty girl that pretty 18 year old girl
you're actually a boy and you need to
mutilate yourself that is such a
transparent she's not a boy and she's
she wasn't a boy when she underwent the
surgery and she's
still not a boy now that she recognizes
that she's a woman she probably has some
resentment maybe not hopefully you know
but i probably would have some
resentment in a culture
and at these sicko doctors who would
take advantage of me the lies are so
transparent obviously this one that a
boy is a girl the lies are
even more transparent though jen saki is
trying to convince us of something even
more preposterous
jen saki is trying to convince us that
joe biden is energetic
what more can you tell us about the
president's
health regime we hear he's lifting
weights what sort of
weights is he lifting does he have a
personal trainer and what happened to
his peloton bike did he bring it to the
to the white house i didn't know where
this was going um
but i'm intrigued by it um i i will say
i have nothing to read out on the
president's uh
private exercise regime uh but i can
tell you having traveled with him
a fair amount um sometimes he's hard to
keep up with
sometimes he's hard to keep like when he
goes wandering off in the middle of the
night and doesn't know where he is i
suppose that would be hard to keep up
but i don't think that during the usual
course of the day he's particularly hard
to keep up with joe do you remember
during the campaign
joe biden would be he'd be walking out
of an office there's a video of this
he's walking out of an office and you've
got
one of his staffers holding him by the
arm like you would hold an elderly
relative and say okay over here
and the reporters are saying hey mr
biden mr biden
they said no questions no questions
please i guess joe wasn't having a good
day
they'll call a lid on campaign events at
what like 1 30 in the afternoon
no he's not give me a break gents i get
it
i know that press secretaries have to
spin but you cannot you can convince me
of a lot of things
but you cannot convince me that joe
biden is energetic
if they're lying to you about that what
else are they lying to you about if
they're lying to you
about the origins of the virus what else
are they lying to you about
if they're lying to you about when the
vaccine's going to come out what else
are they lying to you about if they're
lying to you about boys being girls and
girls being boys what else are they
lying to you about if you want to break
through the lies
i think you should check out my friend
liz wheeler's new
show you know liz wheeler liz wheeler
had a popular tv show then she went away
she disappeared where'd she go i knew
where she went but i'm not sure everyone
else did
she had a baby and took care of that
baby and then
had the baby come and somehow she's like
in fighting for him all the way again
and liz wheeler is launching the liz
wheeler show episode one drops today you
can get it
all over the podcast apps and you can
get it on her youtube channel so go
check that out also
i sat down with liz we talked about a
whole wide range of things
from dr fauci and the masks all the way
to space aliens
you can check that out on my youtube
channel this saturday you're not going
to want to miss liz
either on my channel or on her show
america
may currently be in the middle of a gas
shortage but we are even shorter on
sanity if you ask me that's why you
should join jeremy
ben matt and me tomorrow night for
another
cigar and logic-packed episode of
backstage
streams at seven o'clock eastern 6 p.m
central
on dailywire.com and on our youtube
channel dailywire
by the way if you would rather see
candace in real life than just trending
on twitter or just on the screen
today might be your lucky day if you
sign up as a daily wire member with code
vip you'll get 20
off your new membership and be
automatically entered for a chance to
win a trip to the daily wire studios to
see
candace live you have to check out the
studio you get to see candace you get to
go to front row seats and watch her live
and in action on the show canvas it's
really happening
so don't sleep on it and get the vip
pass right now dailywire.com
subscribe using code vip for 20 off
we'll be right back with a lot more
jen saki says that joe biden is
sometimes he's tough to keep up with oh
man he's so energetic
judge for yourself there's a
coincidentally
joe biden just gave a commencement
speech the first commencement speech of
his presidency
at the coast guard academy so he was
talking to these young cadets
and coincidentally ronald reagan
also gave a speech to the coast guard
academy ronald reagan
the oldest president in american history
up until that point
then be beat out by trump and then beat
out by
joe biden listen to this two speeches
tell me which one seems more energetic
my coast guard aides have been excellent
one of them taught me that and i quote
the coast guard is that hard nucleus
about which the navy forms in time of
war
i can only assume that you will enjoy
educating your family about
how the coast guard is quote the hard
nucleus around
the navy forms in times of war
you are quite you're a really dull class
only oh now look ronald reagan is one of
the great orators
in american history and joe biden cannot
string a sentence together
but joe biden used to be able to string
a sentence together this is not just
making fun of old joe he's just not
talented at this
joe biden has a lot of deficiencies he's
dishonest and he's not particularly
intelligent but he was always a good
talker the guy always had the gift of
gab
he was a smiling simpering back slapping
politician
that's that's all he did and if you look
at clips of him from 5-10 years ago he
was
speaking just fine but he's slowed down
he's obviously losing something
probably not too difficult to keep the
only way he's difficult to keep up with
is people
have no idea what he's saying is you and
the marmie and the small
nucleus and corn
corn huh what huh you're a doll class
i will say one nice thing about joe
biden joe biden
i have to i want to be fair i want to be
a real journalist unlike the ones on
cable news cnn and all those places
joe biden is reportedly dropping student
loan forgiveness
which is this is a promise he made
during the campaign he said that he was
going to
forgive certain student loans well the
budget is here
and four months into his term people
still want biden to forgive ten thousand
dollars
in federal student loans for every
borrower and according to yahoo finance
probably not going to happen
so that's good this is going to be used
as evidence among squishes that joe
biden is not as radical as he said he
would be
this is a very small minor win
for conservatives in an overall radical
agenda the most
radical agenda ever so yes that's good
i'm glad that joe biden won't be
forgiving 10 gs of student loan debt
this would have been very hard for him
to do
because even though the left wants it
especially the more affluent radical
whiter democrat base really was into
this
but the fact is a relatively small
number of people
graduate from college and have these
sorts of student loans
so you would have a situation where
you'd have people who don't go to
college
subsidizing these relatively affluent
people who do go to college it's just a
political loser for biden so he's going
to drop that
but he's going to be pushing through
lots of radical agenda items we've
already seen that we've seen a hint
at even crazier things like court
packing adding new states
totally upending federalizing elections
so minor win
overall but but uh as a rule the the
administration is the most radical one
we've ever seen how do we fight back
against this well
governor ron desantis is showing us one
way to do it
ron desantis just signed an anti-big
tech bill i love this the anti-big tech
bill
does three things in particular
says that all floridians who are treated
unfairly by big tech companies will have
the right to sue the companies that
violate the law
and win monetary damages so
it safeguards certain rights of
floridians by requiring social media
companies to be transparent
about how they're moderating content
right now it's very opaque they do not
publish the rules and very often they
violate their own rules
to give users proper notice if they're
going to change the rules and it's going
to protect
prevent big tech bureaucrats from moving
the goal posts to silence
viewpoints that they don't like which
really means conservatives okay that's
good i like that
number two the attorney general of
florida can bring action against
big tech companies that violate the law
that's good they'll be using florida's
unfair and deceptive trade practices act
that's really good if they're found to
have violated anti-trust law they'll be
restricted from contracting with any
public entities so they're going to
break up a little bit the relationship
between big tech and the government
and big tech is prohibited from
de-platforming floridian political
candidates
so now you see politicians definitely
going to start protecting themselves
the florida election commission will
impose fines of a quarter million
dollars
per day on any social media company that
d-platforms any candidate for statewide
office and 25 grand per day for deep
platforming candidates
for non-statewide offices so
obviously look any social media user can
just block candidates or not follow
candidates that they don't want to see
but that is a right in desantis view
that belongs to the citizens i like this
i'm glad that they're doing this there
are going to be
as usual three positions on this the
left is going to hate it because the
left uses the big tech companies
to enforce their political agenda
without
democratic accountability right the left
can rely on these private companies
and can rely on the rights you know
decades-long
shilling for private companies to
enforce their political agenda without
having to go through usual
political democratic means okay that's
the left's view then there's the squish
moderate view
which is the well build your own twitter
build your own facebook
this is wrong we need to there's nothing
more conservative than letting hipster
rasputin in silicon valley
silence half of the country that's just
democracy oh
no james madison would be furious that
we're not letting mark zuckerberg
control our politics or something right
that's you can tell my
view of of that particular opinion then
there's the conservative view which is
use the state to put pressure on these
private companies
to stop them from controlling and
dominating our politics i know
some conservatives are going to be
uncomfortable with that because they've
imbibed
this pseudo squishy libertarian bumper
sticker
bush era slogan airing but there's
nothing conservative about letting
hipster rasputin run
our public discourse okay nothing
conservative about that at all
it is good it is positively good and
conservative to use the
enforcement arm of the state wisely
we're not anarchists i know that if you
listen to some of the ridiculous
propaganda
from the squish wing of the gop over the
last 20 years you would think that
that republicans are anarchists that we
don't think it's ever legitimate for the
government to do anything
because we want small government
according to them we don't want small
government we want limited government we
want government to stay within its
limits
we want but we want government to do the
things it's supposed to do and one of
those things is to prevent
zillionaire oligarchs in the most
radical parts of the country
from controlling our entire political
system so good on desantis glad
that he's signing this bill he's not
stopping there though baby no way
ron has his eyes i think on a big
political prize so he's doing a lot as
governor i'm glad to see that incentives
are obviously aligned
ron desantis is going after critical
race theory he's trying to boot it out
of florida classrooms
you can put lipstick on a pig it's still
a pig
and you know you can rename so what
we're doing the department of the
florida
board of education is meeting and they
are addressing this
it's offensive to the taxpayer that they
would be asked to fund
critical race theory that they would be
asked to fund
teaching kids to hate their country and
to hate each other
it's also based on false history
when they try to look back and and
denigrate the founding fathers denigrate
the american revolution
doing all these different things that
even very liberal historians say
is not supported by the facts and so i
think what we need
is we need the constitution back in
classrooms we need to make sure civics
is a priority
but it needs to be taught accurately it
needs to be taught in a fact-based way
not an ideological based way and we are
if we have to play whack-a-mole all over
the state
stopping this critical race theory we
will do it
we'll be taking action don't you worry
all right love it
this is a very conservative perspective
what are the three views on this the
liberal view the left wing view rather
is the one that we need to indoctrinate
kids to hate their country
basically they say the country's evil
we've got to teach them that the country
is evil we've got to teach them that
whiteness is evil and needs to be
abolished this
we got to put this stuff in the
classrooms it's got to be mandatory the
squish view
well maybe we should just have different
perspectives and so in one class they
teach you to hate your country
and then in the other class they teach
you maybe you don't hate your country so
much and that'd be cool
and then there's the conservative view
which is this stuff is poison
this stuff undermines education there is
no real such thing as academic freedom
it's never exist in practice
in the words of bill buckley launching
the conservative movement after world
war ii
he said it was a hoax and a superstition
don't fall for it there's a thought that
undermines thought
and that's the only thought that ought
to be stopped to borrow
an idea from chesterton so you've got to
kick it out you can't just expand the
curriculum forever there's only so many
weeks in the semester there's so many
only so many books you can read if
you're reading abram candy you're not
reading a good book
if you're reading robin d'angelo you are
missing out on reading
a worthwhile book that will teach you
something so boot it out ban them
censor them cancel them get them out of
there that is the conservative
point of view which i expound upon in my
upcoming book speech list controlling
words controlling minds available
now for pre-order critical race theory
is not the only crazy thing that's being
taught in schools
there's a critical race theory don't
forget it's just one derivation of
critical theory
which is actually just one major but
only one component
of the politically correct project but
there are a lot of other crazy things
being taught in schools right now
students attending the columbia grammar
and preparatory school in manhattan this
is a very expensive school i think it
costs just shy of 50 gs a year
to attend they are
being forced to take an explicit class
on porn without parental consent
would be bad enough to force them to
take the class on porn they're not even
telling the parents
echoing sorts of things we've heard a
lot this year where radical educators
will say hey
be careful the problem with zoom class
is the parents will know what's being
taught you got to be very careful
don't you think the parents maybe should
know what's being taught no it's very
bad very bad for their education
so at this school they were teaching a
very explicit porn class and i'm not
just saying like
the birds and the bees and look at this
and look at this flesh mashing up
against this flesh
talking about like very i'm not going to
say it on the show this is a family
program
but but but like really graphic gross
stuff the class involved a slideshow and
a lecture by an instructure
which included lots of raunchy images
lots of presentations on the most
lurid porn genres and only fans which is
the democratization of porn
and if you oppose this sort of thing you
will be called closed-minded oh come on
you're just a prude
you're you're a prude come on that's
fine what could go wrong with porn well
we're hearing what goes wrong with porn
how many people right into this show
i've read them in the mail bag people
write in
all the time and say we got to do
something about porn this is really
bad stuff do you know who's writing it's
not the old fuddy duddies writing in
it's not the boomers the boomers seem to
be the ones who are most fine with porn
they say oh it's not a big deal
they tend to fall a little more in that
squish libertarian camp
oh come on it's not come on every
looking at porn that's as american as
apple pie it's protected by the first
amendment it's not a big deal
but the people who write into me and say
this is a big deal or the young men who
get
hooked on this stuff i think they the
median age is something like 11
according to surveys so they get hooked
on the stuff before they can
know anything about it it ruins their
lives they it messes up their
relationships
it hurts women obviously the industry
hurts women but the just even the kind
of
vision of sex that it presents is very
degrading toward women messes up
people's relationships
there's a epidemic of young men who
who have ed because they're hooked on
porn
they're certain it's not you used to
just read about these stories in japan
apparently this has come to the west
as well it's really really bad stuff
why would that be taught in schools oh
come on keep an open mind
obviously we used to know this in this
country but now we've forgotten it
liberty and licentiousness are not the
same thing they're opposite things if
you arouse people's
vices and base passions you're going to
undermine their true liberty
kick it out fire teachers who push this
not don't just vote with your dollars
vote with your politics use your
government
get this stuff take a lesson from
desantis desantis knows what's up
pay attention to this stuff and kick it
out
porn has become in a certain sense it's
become part of the liturgy of
liberalism that they're saying i won't
get into too graphic
detail of what these liturgical
practices look like but it really has
sort of become part of it it is
something that one enacts it is
considered good do you remember at the
start of covid when people were told
they couldn't see one another
the new york city health department
encouraged people to um
how do i put this to use woody allen's
term to have sex with someone you love
you know alone in a room and uh this was
being encouraged this is a good thing
it's good for your health blow off a
little steam
i've heard this described that in in
historically speaking
our views of the mind tend to map on to
our views
of technology so when
the printing press was big we had this
view that what was being imprinted on
your mind
that's that's going to form your mind to
some degree that's true
when the steam engine was the big
technology we were told you had freud
right you had this idea that you have to
stop
repressing things you need to let off a
little bit of steam right
and to a lesser degree that that's not
quite true now today our view of the
mind is that the mind is like a computer
because the computer is the main
technology so you should be able to
upload things and download things and
also
upgrade your your mind or something like
that
okay i i understand all these various
theories of the mind
when you blow off a little steam with
something like porn you know if you get
when you forget even just porn for a
second with any kind of vice if you
think that if you
commit a vice that's going to blow off a
little steam that's not really how it
works
the more vice you commit the more you're
going to commit the more virtue you
practice the more you're going to
practice that's the way it works we've
known this since good old uncle
aristotle but we seem to have forgotten
it
the purpose of education liberal
education is to train yourself
in that liberty so do it any education
that undermines that
is the sort of thing you got to boot out
of the classroom
speaking of leftist liturgical practices
mayor bill de blasio
says he's going to kneel during an event
in harlem to mark the one year
anniversary of george floyd's death
he's going to kneel for nine minutes and
29 seconds which is the amount of time
that the police officer
derek chauvin was kneeling on george
floyd's neck and back and he's going to
kneel and that's he's going to do it at
the event hosted by
race hustling extortionist al sharpton
and his
national action shakedown network uh and
and this is going to call for the
passage of some new george floyd bill
first of all it seems pretty bizarre to
honor george floyd by
reenacting what his ostensible murderer
did to kill him isn't that weird
like he would never if you were to if a
guy were murdered by
in a shooting would you honor him by
going to the shooting range and just pew
pew pew or or acting that out with your
aunt pew pew and now i'm honoring him no
that's very strange
uh but moreover it's also just
absolutely disgusting that
this absolutely sensationalized event
where that involved the death of a
career criminal
uh who was actively resisting arrest and
committing crimes as he was arrested not
to say that
maybe the cop was using excess force but
i think we heard during that trial that
it didn't seem like he was necessarily
using excessive force he was following
certain protocols but maybe not others
and
anyway it was complicated and the jury
seems to have been compromised as well
and you had political leaders on the
left putting a lot of pressure on the
on the jury to convict him of murder
which the even the judge himself said
it's probably going to help you on
appeal all to say it's a complicated
story it's disgusting
that we have got political leaders
honoring this kind of person
we went through yesterday on the show
how
we're told that there's a an epidemic of
anti-black white supremacist hate crime
in this country and it's just not true
you look at the
statistics black people are much more
likely to commit hate crimes than white
people are
much more likely as a as a percentage of
the pi
as a relative to their proportion of the
population
but you just don't hear about those
stories i had a liberal liberal friend
ask me well why michael why do we always
see these police shootings
because the media want to sensationalize
them to create a
racially divisive narrative that's
that's obviously why and that's what's
going on right now it's disgusting stuff
but even beyond that just look at the
action de blasio's going to kneel down
for the nine minutes
this is a perfectly natural human
longing this is a religious ritual i go
kneel down
on sundays when i'm at mass and i
kneel down to in in the memorial
sacrifice of a death of a redemptive
death
the redemptive death and redeemed
mankind of christ on the cross that's a
that's a liturgy that's a religious
ritual that i'm doing
and all people have religious rituals
moreover they must have religious
rituals because man is a
fundamentally religious being and
when you recognize that you're engaging
in religious liturgy
you can think about it a little more
clearly you can apply more rigor and
logic to
and systematic thought when you're
completely unaware of it
as the left is as bill de blasio is you
get into some really
kooky stuff some really superstitious
stuff speaking of leftist rituals
aoc aoc another another one of the
goddesses and the pantheon
of modern leftism another icon
and quasi-religious figure depending on
who you're talking to
she is opening up about how ever since
the january 6th
insurrection she has been
going through therapy she's had a very
difficult time she still has not
recovered
from that trauma after the sixth i
took some time and
it was really ayanna presley when i
explained to her what had happened to me
like the day of because i ran to her
office
and she was like you need to recognize
trauma
and that this is something that you went
through but we're all going through
and um and it's really important to
pause after that
because that's how you process it and
i feel like i learned this the hard way
after my father had passed away when i
was a teenager
so that happened at a young age and i
socked it away
and i i had to live with that for years
so you're doing therapy yeah oh yeah
i i'm doing therapy but also
i've just slowed down i think
the trump administration had a lot of us
especially latino communities
in a very reactive mode
i have no doubt that aoc uh endured
suffering as a child as a teenager when
her father died coincidentally there's
very strange parallels between
my life and hers because we grew up in
the towns right next to each other at
exactly the same time and i i also lost
a parent when i was a teenager and it's
a very difficult thing i
i do not in any way minimize the
trauma and suffering of that you like to
think that time heals all wounds and
over time you can get over that and go
on and move on and live your life
so i hope she can do that i've no doubt
that's a real trauma i don't think that
january 6 was a real trauma for her
because she lied about it
she i'm sorry let me be more specific
she exaggerated it
she you can't say she lied because all
she ever talked about was her feelings
she said i felt as though
i was about to be killed i felt as
though my life was at risk
so sure i guess that's your feelings i
can't i can't
disagree with what you felt subjectively
but she never was at risk of dying she
wasn't even in the capital that day she
was across the street
or rather down the street it was a bit
of a walk away she was in her office
building and no one busted in there was
actually a cop who came in to protect
her
and she's milked this for all it's worth
and she says i'm i'm just in the trauma
i'm so broken i've had to slow down i'm
in the therapy for this i can't
it's hard to process and i get really
traumatic
we are exalting weakness and
and brokenness in this leftist culture
we are exalting these things we are
actually trying to find ways to claim
that we are
broken hurt aggrieved
disordered unstable it's
got cachet it's got social currency
if you are really that messed up if
you're really that shaken up and you
can't handle it
you should not be in government you
should not be in political leadership
you can't you got to be tough it's hard
but you got to be tough
you gotta move on you gotta take chin up
stiff upper lip and move on no matter
look everybody goes through dramas
everybody goes through suffering
sometimes it's real like
aoc had when she was a teenager
sometimes it's contrived like she
exaggerated in her office building on
january 6th
but whatever it is maybe she felt maybe
she felt terrible on jenny i don't know
but chin up you got to cut this out
we've got to stop
mutilating ourselves ideologically
philosophically physically we've got to
stop
mutilating ourselves and taking things
that are relatively healthy and making
them weaker
and having social currency for grievance
and all trying to grab grievance and
weakness
we've got to get strong if you're not
going to be strong
you're not going to have a flourishing
country
you're going to be mutilating america
i'm michael nolan's the michael knowles
shall see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 today on the
ben shapiro show as evidence amounts
that covet began in a chinese lab
social media's crackdown on the lab
league theory looks worse and worse we
discuss what has changed on the first
year
commemoration of george floyd's death
and the media are fascinated with joe
biden weightlifting that's today on the
bench bureau show give it a listen